So Leute, wir haben mal relativ spontan am Start jetzt.
Ich muss noch alles starten, ich hab noch meinen Vorschaurechner und so gar nicht an, aber der Stream braucht eh ein bisschen.
Bis die Notifications raus sind, bis Twitch das gecheckt hat und so, das dauert ja alles immer ein bisschen.
Excellent, so.
Mal meinen Vorschaurechner starten.
Ich hab da immer noch Skype drauf installiert. Skype und Avira.
Alter, das ist so fail.
Warum hab ich den Crap überhaupt drauf?
Lul.
So, gut, wunderbar. Passt.
Ah, Teams hat wieder mal den Sound umgestellt. Ich hör's direkt.
Lul. Warum, warum, warum? Alter Teams.
So, äh, Recording Levels. Na okay, ein bisschen, bisschen umgestellt.
Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen, aber muss ja so sein bei Teams.
Ja Leute, wie gesagt, ihr wart eben nicht da, wo ich's schon erzählt hab, weil das Stream hat keine Notifications rausgeschickt.
Also ich bin jetzt nochmal spontan on, wir basteln jetzt ein bisschen weiter an PreisChamp.
Weil ich hab heute, äh, ups, lul.
Weil ich hab heute, ich zeig's euch nochmal, der PreisChamp ist am Start.
So sieht der bei euch nicht aus, bei euch sieht er so aus.
Ähm, und ich hab heute ein Analytic Tool installiert, was nix trackt.
Also ihr müsst jetzt hier keine DSGVO Anzeige, Anzeige ist raus machen.
Es trackt einfach nur Seitenaufrufe, sonst nix.
Nur irgendwelche Cookies oder, äh, IPs oder sonst was.
Das lockt von euch gar nix.
Und ich hab gesehen, dass seit heute Morgen, genau und Impresso ganz anders steht.
Wieso sind die nicht in Deutschland? Das ist auch nicht von mir die Seite, keck weh.
Ähm, und ich hab gesehen, dass seit heute Morgen, ich mach mal die VM kurz an.
Ähm, dass seit heute Morgen waren 780 oder so Leute drauf.
Dabei hab ich das noch nirgendwo gepostet.
Und ich hab permanent 5 Leute oder so, die da drauf Preischampen.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm bevor du morgen weitermachst, kannst du auch heute schon weitermachen.
Und zwar, was ich denn die ganze Zeit machen will, ist, dass wir eben noch die restlichen Dinger anzeigen, ne.
Also aktuell ist es ja so, der Preischamp, man kann sich den benachrichtigen lassen, ja.
Ähm, der zeigt ja immer an, wenn was Neues reinkommt.
Aber, ich mein, so ein Pop-Up, wo einfach drin steht, welche Shops gerade was da haben, ist natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Da mach ich hier oben noch so ein paar Punkte, da kann man draufklinken, Pop-Up auf oder sowas.
Ja.
Und, die eigentliche Preischamp-Site ist jetzt auch...
Los, warum lecken das so?
Alter, mach mal kurz, mach mal kurz, alles, alles zu, äh...
Ah, ok, das leckt wahrscheinlich, weil die so lang offen war.
Ich mein, das eine ist Java und das andere ist ne JavaScript-Anwendung, da muss man sich nicht wundern.
Ich mach mal alles zu, dann entleckt's hoffentlich wieder.
Terminal kann ich aufmachen.
Ja, und es hatte einer ne richtig gute Idee, man könnte UVP-Preise daneben schreiben.
Was haltet ihr denn von der Idee? Ich find das ist eigentlich ne coole Sache.
Dass man sieht, was es normalerweise kostet.
Ah, das war zum Testen hier, ne ne ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Das können wir alles wegschmeißen.
Ist die Anwendung schon im Container drin?
Ähm, ne, aber das, ich hab mir noch nen zweiten Software gemietet, für die eigentliche, also für die nicht-Beta-Variante.
Ähm, da läuft der Tracker schon im Container und das Analytictool auch.
So.
Kannst du Datensätze kaufen? Kommt drauf an, was du bezahlst.
Prinzipiell kannst du bei mir alles kaufen.
Kommt nur auf den Preis an.
Ok, fast alles.
Genau, das hier wird die normale Seite.
Wenn man da aktuell drauf geht, kriegt man ne ganz tolle Meldung.
Wurde das im Stream entwickelt?
Ein bisschen, teilweise.
Deswegen, denkt dran, die richtige Seite ist die hier.
Ja, das, ich muss mal gucken.
Also, ich will da nicht so viel manuell reinschreiben.
Aber jetzt machen wir erst mal.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal das mit UVP und die Shops anzeigen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Und morgen muss ich das ein bisschen modularer machen.
Ich hab vorhin schon angefangen, aber ich hab mir gedacht, mach einfach in Stream weiter.
Weil ich hatte ja bisher alles in einer großen Seite.
Guckt, ich hatte bisher alles.
Alter, nerven nicht rum.
Ich hatte alles in meiner Main-App-Datei drinne.
Die wurde mit der Zeit ein bisschen...
Sag mal, warum lag das denn so?
57%? Was?
Ok, jetzt geht's.
Was auch immer. Vielleicht soll ich mal updaten.
Mal sehen, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Baust du auch für paar tausend, auch ein Trojaner ein?
Wie die Chinesen, klar.
Aber ein paar tausend reichen dafür nicht.
Da musst du schon, da musst du schon ein bisschen mehr in die Tasche greifen,
wenn ich dir sowas einbauen soll.
Ah, Indisch. Exzellent, exzellent.
Beste.
Gestern auch hier Engine gefuddert.
Aber nur notgedrungen.
Ich wollte gestern eigentlich Chicken Burger bestellen.
Bin auf Lieferando drauf.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht zeigen, weil dann muss ich Paypal eingeben.
Aber wenn man Paypal eintippt,
da kommt doch immer, bevor man bezahlt, nochmal so,
wollen sie auch wirklich bezahlen.
Die Seite kennt ihr ja.
Wollen sie auch wirklich bezahlen.
Und da habe ich irgendwie im Kopf abgeschaltet
und habe mir gedacht, ich habe schon bezahlt
und bin in anderen Tab und irgendwann so 12.30 Uhr denke ich mir dann so,
Alter, das Essen könnte doch langsam echt mal kommen.
Das Essen kam als nett.
Und irgendwann gehe ich dann wieder auf die Seite zurück von Lieferando
und das ist immer noch mal im Checkout Prozess.
Verkackt, ja.
Was weiß jemand aus dem Chat, wie es aussieht,
wenn ich das Charakterset von der Oracle Datenbank, oh je.
Ich hoffe, das ist auch Kobol Software, die drauf zugreift.
Nee, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte alles bisher in meiner Main App.
Das wird ein bisschen viel.
Das hier kann, by the way, auch da raus
und muss in die Component rein.
Wie das scopet.
Da wird es nämlich ein bisschen näherer.
Ich bin gerade dabei, das ein bisschen zu modularisieren.
Jetzt bauen wir erst einmal Folgendes ein.
Erst einmal die Geschichte mit,
vielleicht muss ich gleich neu starten, schauen wir mal.
Erstmal die Geschichte mit Pop-up und mit UVP.
Ach Mist, ich habe ja lokal gar keine, lau, klar.
Ich habe hier lokal gar kein Street Merchant laufen.
Da muss ich das lokal, oh, ich habe geupdatet.
Okay Leute, ich muss Update abwarten.
Der updated gerade Elektron, oh no, da kann er nur in die Hose gehen.
Gibt es Vorteile oder Nachteile?
C-Sharp.NET auf Windows oder Linux zu programmieren?
Ich würde es nicht unbedingt jetzt so richtig hart Vorteile und Nachteile nennen.
Ich meine,.NET ist auf Windows entstanden.
Dementsprechend hast du auch noch viele Dinge, die nur unter Windows funktionieren.
Ganze WPF-Geschichte, ganze Windows Forms-Geschichte.
Falls du dir UVP geben willst, ist das Ganze natürlich auch nur Windows.
Ganze DirectX-Geschichten sind nur Windows.
Das sind einige Sachen, die sind Windows Only, also alles was GUI angeht.
Aber ansonsten, muss ich sagen, entwickle ich lieber auf Linux mittlerweile.
Also Server Zeug auf jeden Fall, weil es hat Vorteile, die Sachen auf dem System zu entwickeln,
die, wo es später auch drauf läuft.
Du hast auch einen weiteren Grund, warum ich nicht Dual Boot, sondern die Sachen in der VM laufen lasse.
Also Leute, ich muss euch mal sagen, während das Updaten zählt, sage ich mal was zu.
Der Sirius Max, der ist gerade im Chat, der hat ein richtig nice...
Max, kann ich das im Stream zeigen?
Oder noch was, ich will nicht den privaten Chat-Verlauf zeigen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was da alles drin steht.
Hast du die Bilder irgendwo links zu oder so?
Dann zeige ich die nämlich mal im Stream.
Der Sirius Max hat nämlich ein richtig cooles GUI gebaut für Preischamp.
Und diese Seite hier, diese Übersichtsseite, werde ich aber in irgendeiner Form lassen,
weil lustigerweise, es wirkt erst mal kontraproduktiv, dass da nicht direkt das günstigste steht und so.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, das hat so, jetzt lacht mich mal aus,
das hat so einen gewissen Gambling-Faktor, den die Leute geil finden.
Das habe ich in den Analytics gesehen.
Es gibt so viele Leute, die sitzen, obwohl ich es noch nirgendwo geteilt habe, das Ding eigentlich.
Die sitzen den ganzen Tag da und gucken da drauf, wie die Kästchen plinken.
Und ich finde es auch insofern ganz gut, weil da steht halt immer, genau das letzte Wasser gefunden hat.
Und das ist insofern ganz cool, was du hier siehst, ist halt wirklich das allerletzte Wasser gefunden hat.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt das aktuell aller billigste, aber das letzte.
Das heißt, wenn du hier hingehst, dann sind die Chancen gut, dass es auch lieferbar ist.
Guck hier, noch eins auf Lager.
So, und ich werde es dann so machen, ich mache hier noch einen Detailknopf hin,
und da sieht man dann den ganzen aktuellen Kram.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Design vom Serious Max an.
Das ist richtig...
Gut, Firefox ist aber neu gestanden.
Haben wir es jetzt.
Genau, guck mal, das ist das Design, was der Serious Max gebaut hat für Preisschamp.
Das ganze ist DSDX.
Das macht im Prinzip nichts anderes als ein Postrequest schicken, einmal beim Seitenaufruf.
Das trackt nichts, es macht einfach gar nichts.
Im Prinzip das, was eigentlich schon alles gemacht wurde, ist halt einfach ein
was
eigentlich schon eingebaut ist
guck mal was er gebaut hat hier
ich weiß nicht genau in welcher Reihenfolge wir das machen
aber ich finde das hat er echt cool gemacht
so das heißt man kann erstmal auswählen
ich glaube das ist die Ursprungsübersicht seit wie lange was verfügbar ist
genau die muss man noch ein bisschen anders machen
genau da kannst du auswählen was du alles angucken willst
und du kannst sogar sagen welche Shops dich interessieren und welche nicht
also das hat er echt nice gemacht und vor allem
die Detailansicht ich glaube das ist das Ding was ich wirklich erstmal auch
übernehmen werde
die Detailansicht hat er cool gemacht
vor allem dass das Ding nicht einfach Verkaufspreis heißt sondern Stonks
das muss später auch so heißen
ich habe Auferglocker schon längst rausgenommen
ist nicht mehr drin
Stonksverlauf heißt das dann
da machen wir auch den Stonksmann als Bild hin
ja hat er cool gemacht oder
sieht echt richtig nice aus
jetzt muss ich mal lokal gucken ob ich lokalnetz starten kann
ah gut geht wieder sehr gut
das ist nur Prototyp ja ja
mit was hast du das gemacht
hast du da selbst HTML gemacht oder ist das eher so
Image Bearbeitungs Markup
Mockup Ding
Adobe XD
das wollte ich mir schon lange mal angucken hab ich nie gemacht
Slay.Teddy 8 Monate Dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Subscription
bezahlt werden Leute prinzipiell ich ja auch nicht
ich muss mal kurz hoch scrollen ich glaube ich hab nämlich Subs übersehen
kann das sein
Leute hab ich Subs übersehen? Nee ich glaub nicht
sorry falls ich Subs übersehen hab
was ist das View Format
wenn du View eingibst in Google
das erste was du findest ist das richtige
ne Google AdSense brauch ich nicht wie gesagt ich hab ne eigene Sache die
das zählt und mehr als Seitenaufrufe und Seitenleuten die aktuell drauf sind
brauch ich nicht
was hab ich jetzt gesagt wollen wir einbauen
das mit dem Popup ne
dass das in dem Popup anzeigt was alles verfügbar ist von welchen Händlern
achso du meinst AdSense Werbung
wie funktioniert das überhaupt
hat ja jemand Erfahrung mit
kommt dann hier oben automatisch auf der Seite so ein AdSense Ding oder was
Desktop App easy Elektron App
so also wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Popup
weil Leute ich denke hier den UVP hinzuschreiben ist nicht so sinnvoll
oder ich finde die Seite ist eigentlich relativ gut wie sie ist
das verwirrt die Leute nur wenn hier noch irgendwie UVP dabei steht
ja ich mach da auch ein Impressum hin wie gesagt ich schreib da einfach mein Vater hin
der hat zwar nichts damit zu tun aber der hat mich auch schon ab und zu mal ein
bisschen gescampt
dann kriegt der das jetzt
nee wisst ihr was ich mach ich hab mir das schon überlegt ich schreib da einfach
hier ein Impressum
Projekt bei Max FPS und mach einen Link auf meine About YouTube Page und gut ist
und im Zweifelsfall sollen die bei meinem Netzwerk anrufen
die wissen dann zwar überhaupt nicht was Sache ist
da ruft da irgendwie einer ansagt
euer Preis Jam voll kacke ihr Sack und die denkt hä alter was wir sind
wie immer die Adresse steht auch auf der YouTube About Page also
passt so
also
mit was fangen wir jetzt an
wie gesagt ich glaube hier den UVP hinzuschreiben sackt ziemlich
das das würde dann das würde dann so aussehen
ähm
dann mach ich mal wieder reinfuhren wo ich hier bin
Shop
Price
da wird dann irgendwie drinne stehen 1000
UVP oder so
ups
brrr
Kacquait
ich und html ey wo ist das Problem
wo ist das Problem
Ado gehts gehts
das ist kacke ich mein natürlich könnte ich das noch ein bisschen größer machen
aber das sieht das das sieht trotzdem doof aus oder
dass sie das sie trotzdem ich mein man könnte es vielleicht dahinter schreiben
weil da ist ja noch Platz
irgendwie so
aber so wirklich nice ist das okay da müsste ich breiter machen wenn ich das
dahinter schreib
ich finde das mit UVP nicht schlecht
ich finde die Idee gut schreibe ich auf die Detailseite weil dann weiß man was
das mal ursprünglich eigentlich sein sollte
ja also in der Übersichtseite finde ich muss das muss das echt nicht hin
so also dann machen wir jetzt mal ein Popup
ich kann übrigens immer nicht merken wie das mit dem Popup geht Dialog genau
so
was mit der CPU Last abgeht
das ist der Street Merchant
aber ich kann den jetzt übrigens ausmachen
weil ich habe die Zeit von 15 Minuten auf 60 Minuten zum Testen hochgestellt
prozentualer Unterschied zum UVP
das können wir alles auf die Detailseite schreiben ich schreibe mir das mal auf
das ist eine gute Idee
weil auf die Detailseite kommt aktuell nicht so viel drauf so hier
ja schon besser
Ruby
können wir das mal aufschreiben
ja das ist eine gute Idee
mach ich dann
das Latein das ist Fake Latein
das ist dieses Fake Latein zum Texte testen
das benutzen total viele
ist das ein Projekt von Max? Das hier?
Das? Ja
vielleicht ist das auch kein Fake was auch immer ist mir doch egal
ich muss einfach nur wissen wie ich ein Popup mache ordentliches Popup
also Slidermann Popup
das Slidermann Popup nehmen wir das ist gut
Dialog
excellent
Stack Overflow Triffen Copy Paste Programming
schreibe ich gleich in meine
mein Lebenslauf kenne ich damit aus
so wo machen wir das jetzt am besten hin
Popup ist eigentlich egal wo das ist
ok
also wir brauchen erst mal Buttons um das Popup aufzumachen
richtig Agile
Moment ich brauche einen Button um das Popup ah guck mal da hab ich doch sogar schon einen Button
um das Popup aufzumachen
das hatte ich mal vor einer Weile eingebaut guck mal hier
wie findet ihr das da zum Popup öffnen für Detailview
also es gibt zwei Varianten wie man das machen kann
ähm
entweder das komplette
das komplette Ding öffnet das Popup
außer halt der Shoplink
oder sowas in der Richtung
weil nochmal Punkte oben macht es fast schon ein bisschen zu überladen oder?
egal ich mach erst mal das ich ich ich bastel erst mal das Popup dass das gut
ausschaut
das komplette wegen mobile
ich hab's auf mobile ausprobiert also
Alerts zu aktivieren und deaktivieren geht auch mobile ziemlich gut
übrigens
auf Android funktioniert es prinzipiell
hab ich bei mir auf dem Tablet probiert iOS keine Chance die haben halt keinen
Notification API
da muss man sich was anderes überlegen
für iOS brauchst du eine native App für
Notifications
ich mein ich könnte da draus easy eine native App machen
es gibt ja sogar
Webseiten zu ähm
native App Converter
aber da müsste ich mich beim
müsste ich mich für ein App Store anmelden und sowas
da hab ich ehrlich gesagt
kein Bock drauf ja
diese
diese drei Punkte kennt auch jeder für mehr Info ja deswegen in dem Fall ist
eigentlich ein schlecht aber vielleicht macht es ein bisschen zu voll
so ich mach jetzt erstmal den Dialog rein und das Overlay
ähm
la
was haben die da wieder in ihrem
was haben die da wieder in
ich bin verwirrt die haben so viel Gedöns mit da hier drinnen
brauchen wir noch alles gar nicht
wir brauchen einen Dialog Variable das ist aber auch alles
Dialog ist true
wir wollen es ja standardmäßig anzeigen
und
achso nee Moment haha
nein nein wir wollen das garantiert nicht standardmäßig anzeigen
weil sonst hab ich gleich drei Pop-ups offen das will ich ja nur bei
können wir mal ausprobieren
so und wie sag ich ihm jetzt dass er das aufmacht
Team Model
Dialog
oh ich hab wirklich 50 Pop-ups jetzt gemacht
eine äußerst clevere Idee
exzellent
so macht man's
wow jawoll
Poggers
und dieses Icon hat ein bisschen zu hohen Z Index würde ich sagen
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das mit dem Z Index gemacht hab ehrlich gesagt
ey Leute
was denn das
seht ihr auch was ich seh
gehst du fort
die
guckt mal das Icon
guckt euch mal genau an
das Icon ist unterschiedlich groß
guckt mal
das triggert mich übelst
das Icon ist deaktiviert größer als aktiviert
seht ihr das
das ist ein anderes Icon
triggert euch sowas nicht auch
wir haben Bell-Outline und Bell-Cancel-Outline
wir brauchen ein anderes Notification-Symbol
da kann ich nicht
nee da kann ich nicht mit leben Leute
nicht so einfach wie ihr euch das vorstellt
Moment ist das ist das auf Live auch so
ja
ja das ist live auch so
ok Bell was nehmen wir für ein anderes schönes Notification
wir können den Wecker nehmen wir können Wecker an Wecker aus
gibt ja zig varianten
Alarm light off
Alarm light on
Kreis mit Ausrufezeichen
da denken zu wenig Leute an Alarm
Alarm Alarm
Alarm und Alarm off
das da
aber die sind auch unterschiedlich groß
nehmen wir das Hütchen
wir nehmen das Hütchen wir nehmen Alarm light off
und Alarm light
ja das ist gut so ist das schön
so ist das gut
schon viel besser oder
aha yes
kommt mal es ist jetzt standardmäßig on
wait a minute
die Glocke sah schöner aus ja das stimmt
aber die Glocke ist unterschiedlich groß
das geht nicht
kein exzellent
na gut wisst ihr was wir machen können also
Glocke
cancel
ist größer
da machen wir das normale
wie geht man hier size an 40
dann machen wir das normale einfach größer
24 26
ha guck mal guck mal
ich glaube ich glaube jetzt gut jetzt guck mal
guck mal jetzt wird sogar die Glocke hier kleiner
was ist wenn man die auf
size 24 jetzt macht das was da
dass das die ios nupties auch treffen
der ändert sich tatsächlich was
ich weiß
bin da ja noch
ja ich weiß ihr freut die leute denkt jetzt alle max was hast du für
Probleme was ist mit der Glocke
war das
ok leute wisst ihr was wir lassen ist jetzt ich muss es jetzt ignorieren
sonst mache ich da sonst mache ich da drei drei stunden jetzt dran rum
wir machen jetzt pop-up pop-up pop-up machen wir jetzt pop-up also machen
wir erst mal temporär diese diese icons da oben
dialog ist falls wenn wir auf die icons klicken
trotz click dialog
einfach mal realohnt
der z index ist nicht so gut von dem 1
weiß gar nicht warum ich den set index hoch gemacht habe hatte das
irgendeinen sinn irgendwas war kaputt glaube ich ich weiß aber nicht mehr
was scheint so hast du auch wie viel wörtz per minen keine ahnung ist aber
auch vollkommen irrelevant weil man sitzt zum größten teil ist mal am
googeln oder oder am überlegen
echt es gibt einen github issue damit muss man es jetzt angucken
bell in konsistenz sie ist ich bin ich der einzige den das nervt guckt euch an
guckt euch an das kann er nicht sein
ja wie
was soll das erst erst mal ich muss daumen runtergeben bin ich hier
irgendwo noch eingeloggt wo bin ich bin ich irgendwo noch eingeloggt github
ne hat er glück
ne ohne auslangen geht nicht das sieht
sieht dumm aus moment aber das sieht dumm aus
die ist richtig die ist richtig die andere bell aber nicht aber die sieht
dumm aus dass mit outland ist viel besser oder
das doch mal das mit outland ist viel besser das sieht weniger weniger
gewichtig aus irgendwie
erstmal youtube video mal ok also wir machen erst mal das pop-up bevor wir
ewig ewig ewig rum also ok gut also was verschreiben wir da rein was was
verschreiben wir da rein in das in das
der jet macht daumen runter ich hab den daumen runter gemacht
ha ha ha Leute perfekt so muss es sein
oh
hack wait
achso ich hab's beendet
ok der dialog sieht kacke aus
guck mal wie dumm der ausfaded
warum faded der so dumm aus
ok das kommt weg
ja so ist viel besser
und
äh wenn der dialog da ist
der triggert die
der triggert die scrollleiste
und jetzt ist die scrollleiste weg
ich sollte die scrollleiste überhaupt noch ausblenden
halt scrollbar
das braucht nämlich keiner
ist weg
7.000
ey wenn der jetzt das
projekt quittet ich will nicht schuld sein
ja
ist immer noch da
ah yes
gleich viel besser
ich hasse das wenn seiten rumzuckeln
wenn sie eigentlich still sein sollten
und ganz ehrlich ne scrollbar
oh nicht hidden
nicht hidden da kann man ja nicht mal scrollen
nee nee hidden geht nicht
ähm
nee nee moment
hidden geht nicht
ich will noch scrollen können
das wird ja so kompliziert
ja
ich muss viel agieren
wie hab ich das denn bei monac s
gemacht
getappt
wie hab ich das bei monac s gemacht
kannst du nicht
die eigens manuell sicherlich irgendwie
aber da hab ich eigentlich keinen
nerv drauf
äh appview style
ah html web
kids scrollbar weiß
ich wusste das ging irgendwie
ah yes
und jetzt kann man noch scrollen und die scrollbar ist weg
und die webseite zuckelt nicht mehr
so muss das sein
sehr schön
exquisite würde ich sagen
ok jetzt müssen wir erstmal
ein paar infos hier reinkriegen also
wie bauen wir denn so
wie bauen wir denn das popup auf
aber jetzt ist die scrollbar weg das macht nix wenn die scrollbar weg ist
die scrollbar brauchst du doch nicht
wozu die ma
jetzt mal ernsthaft
es scrollt jeder mit dem maus grad du kannst mit der tastatur scrollen
wer klickt da unten wer klickt
meint ihr wirklich es gibt leute die probleme haben
wenn die scrollbar weg ist
hier ist das css
mit der scrollbar
meint ihr ernsthaft es gibt leute die probleme haben
mit der scrollbar die boomer
haben das eh im fullscreen und im fullscreen
ist das breit genug
so
also das popup popup
was schreiben wir denn da rein
also
wir hatten das da serious max gemacht
zeig mal her
das ist ja quasi der
der detail
detail view den wir brauchen
so mehr
ne das stimmt nicht so ganz
ich will den detail view
von einer serie haben
preisverlauf verfügbarkeit
machen wir da nicht rein an der stelle
das machen wir vielleicht oben als grafen
so was was machen wir da als überschrift
ich bin immer so übelst unkreativ
was solche sachen angeht
wie die überschrift
keck weh
stonks
kommt da als überschrift
überschrift
warum ist der
warum ist der kart text denn so fett
ich will eigentlich den close button oben rechts an
haben die da haben die da einen
example für close button oben rechts
das mag zwar nicht so oben links
wie haben die denn hier gemacht
den close button
button toolbar
toolbar button
ich glaub die music ist vorbei
hier toolbar button
button in die toolbar
ok machen wir easy
jawoll
ok wir haben close button
da kann ich nämlich
jetzt mal ehrlich was ist euch lieber
den close button da ohne in die eck
oder obelinks
ich find obelinks den close button
wir können den close button nach oben rechts machen
die apple leute wollen den bestimmt oben links haben
rechts
wie macht man das rechts
ich glaub spacer oder so
oh nee jetzt muss ich das jedes mal
oh fuck
so macht man das
das bestimmt nicht
keck
weiß nicht wie man das rechts
macht
jede ecke
ich lass den jetzt links ich weiß nicht wie ich den rechts mach
was schreiben wir da jetzt
sinnvolles rein
wir könnten es auf jeden fall schon mal breiter machen
man kann übrigens auch sagen
fullscreen
dann kommt das so raus
was meint ihr fullscreen
oder lieber overlay
lieber overlay oder
ja
da siehst du nämlich schon ein bisschen was im hintergrund passiert
du kannst auch hier hinklicken zum weg machen
du kannst escape drücken zum weg machen
overlay mobile fullscreen
oh jetzt wirds advanced
mal gucken was der mobile überhaupt da draus macht
da erkennst du ja nix mobile
ja ok mobile müssen wir das wahrscheinlich fullscreen machen
oder zumindest auf dem kleinsten
auf dem kleinsten dings muss man es dann fullscreen machen
was passiert wenn ich die maximale breite raus nehme
ah
ja das ist ja eigentlich noch besser
das ist gut
oh bäm
volle pulle
da kann man dann auch sich den graph angucken
wenn man da drauf steht
ok wir müssen jetzt was sinnvolles reinschreiben
also ich würd vorschlagen
wie mach ich das jetzt dass ich nur mal einen dialog krieg
dialog krieg
ich hab ne idee
gleich
warte mal
ist das so dass der alles anzeigt
genau
oh
ach ne da machts ja nie wieder aus
ok ich muss jetzt sagen
if
ich will das nur
bei der 3600 mal zum testen haben
oder bei der 3900 mal zum testen
ok info
serious name
ah yes
ok jetzt kann ich ihn zwar nicht zumachen aber das macht nix
wunderbar wunderbar
ich will ja auch nicht zumachen ich will aber sinnvolles reinschreiben
ich muss den graf im hintergrund übrigens wieder anschmeißen
graf ja
nutzt du unterschiedliche mäusen tastatur für den linux
und den windows pc oder einen kvm switch
äh das ist ne vm
das ist ne vm das mach ich alles mit der gleichen tastatur
ok wunderbar
also
da kommt jetzt sowas rein in dieses
also der titel
titel ist schonmal eindeutig
das waren wir uns ja vorhin einig
donks
ja
jetzt ist es rechts
warum ging das mit dem
warum ging das mit dem button nicht
ah jetzt gehts
what the fuck
aber wenn er vor ist gehts nicht
hä
ich hatte doch exakt das gleiche eben
kek wait
ich hatte den spacer im button drin
oh dann hab ich mich vertan
ja kein wunder das ist nicht funktioniert
hat
donks
ok
äh moment
view toolbar title
title title
title
alter lade mal
ich weiß das im hintergrund übrigens abgeht
ok view toolbar title
vielleicht wirds da ein bisschen größer
oder so mal gucken
donks
das sieht wie anders aus
ah guck mal donks ist groß
perfekt
donks close
jawoll
so also
da kommt jetzt nicht info hin
da kommt jetzt die infos von der grafikkarte
rein also shops
das heißt wir machen da jetzt irgendwie
so ne
beautify list
oh das können wir richtig richtig
äh unleashed triumph
du kannst selbst ausprobieren
geh mal auf beta.preisjam.org
dann siehst du es
du kannst dir dann auch live zugucken wie es updated
du kannst dich sogar übrigens
benachrichtigen lassen
ok was ist denn hier ne schöne liste
wie können wir das mal darstellen
ich würd sagen mit so nem avatar
feld
wie gesagt nachdem ich der übelste
css noob bin
so hier
in der richtung stellen wir das da
das ist glaube ich ganz
sinnvoll
hier machen wir das
hier könnte man noch ne logo vom shop hin machen
und da kommen dann
die die einzelheiten rein
oder
ne so so machen was so ist perfekt
so machen was
hier kommt der shopname hin und da kommt der preis
link und sowas hin
was ali
wie ist der typ
ist es zufall dass die beautify sachen wie android aussehen
nein das ist absichtlich
android material design
äh
aha
muss ich da ne
row nehmen
ah
ok copy paste mal das mal
äh
pack weight
da ist jetzt ein bisschen wenig drin
ah moment
warte
ich glaub ich hab nicht alles kopiert warte mal warte mal
he
was
was machen die denn da
ach das hier ist die ein
das hier ist die
das hier ist die eigentliche liste
ok ich bin
auch gradig verwirrt was css shit angeht
und jetzt
ah
gut sieht schon besser aus
so wir schmeißen jetzt diesen ganzen mist raus
list item weg
erstmal alles schön per copy paste
machen so so wie sich das gehört
so
so genau so wollen wir die shops haben
den ganzen anderen crap da kommt auch weg
ja genau
ja
und da schreiben wir jetzt die ganzen shops hin
sieht jetzt aus wie android kontakte
ja gut
die icons und so kommen ja anders
anderweitig color ist mir erstmal
wurscht
gibt es ein schönes icon
für den shop
wobei hier könnte man
ohne mist hier könnte man eigentlich
jeweilige logo vom shop verlinken
wo mach ich das mit dem avatar hin
jetzt hier
naja das geht ja nicht
ich brauch mal nen bild
copy image address
ja perfekt
da is er
alles klar
so und als titel kommt dann sowas hin wie
ich keine ahnung
asus
oh leute
moment
stand da grad was von asus
asus kann man jetzt mittlerweile direkt
ok
da fehlt noch abstand
das hätt ich nicht gesehen
so
also da kommt sowas wie asus rein
das kommt dann alles untereinander
hier unten kommt dann sowas wie
der aktuelle
preis also sowas wie
sowas
kann man das dahin machen
ah
das ist aber nicht schön aligned
das sieht ziemlich kacke aus
ah
ja so ist das schöne line
so gefällt mir das
der absolute
ui boss
genau und so und von der ide her wird jetzt
warte mal 2 line
was gab es denn noch 2 line 3
3 line
3 line ja 3 line ist fast noch besser
weil da können wir unten drunter noch den link machen
ne den link mach ich hier oben hin
das hat keinen sinn wenn ich das doppelt mach
subheader kann man auch machen
item avatar
man kann auch was noch header machen
ach ne hier
vlist item subtitle
es gibt nen item title und nen
subtitle den man nehmen kann
ne hab ich doch schon
wo ist jetzt der unterschied zwischen 3
hä
dass ich dann noch den subheader machen kann
was ist der unterschied zwischen 2 line und 3 line
lines
hä
da einfach
ist da einfach im zweifelsfall
mehr platz also könnte ich
einfach so 2 sachen nehmen
ah da ist einfach
mehr platz
wobei das ist bei dem anderen ist auch mehr platz
ah da ist das ein bisschen
ok da ist das ein bisschen gestauchter
was findet ihr schöner ich glaub 3
ja ein bisschen weiter auseinander
ist schon
nicht verkehrt
so und da machen wir jetzt mal nen link
äh
genau asus
kw wie sieht das als link
aus
brauchbar
ich will dass das kw
eigen bleibt wir können da
tatsächlich dumme
dumme bildchen rein machen
ok
so würde dann ein eintrag aussehen
allerdings
bisschen wenig oder
schriftgröße auf punkt erhöhen ist es glaube
ich schon
wir könnten aber die schriftgröße allgemein
jetzt allgemein ein bisschen klein
aber
naja jetzt wir müssen erstmal die logik
wir müssen erstmal die logik basteln
also wir würden jetzt
ja nicht einfach da hardcode
oder was reinschreiben sondern das was verfügbar ist
das heißt
ich muss jetzt erstmal von meinem backend
abfragen
was alles verfügbar ist
dann sollte ich den dialog
vielleicht doch als
einzelnes element machen
sonst lade ich ja auf einmal alles
das sagt ziemlich
wir laden einfach mal alles
das ist ja nur lokal
das mache ich dann aber später nicht so
also ich habe hier schon was eingebaut
dass man abfragen kann und zwar
genau
man kann alle shops abfragen
ich sollte mein password und user
in password save schreiben
naja alles klar ist Bescheid
genau ich kriege eine liste von den letzten
produkten von jedem shop
wenn ich das übergebe
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus zum abfragen
localhost 5000
craftql
rtx 3070
definitely not poc
ne
also
also jetzt müssen wir erstmal abfragen
was wir haben wollen
schema
ja also wir wollen
querying history
oh hab ich
ach query genau
so
also history
so und da wollen wir jetzt
abfragen also was brauchen wir
was brauchen wir bei so einer status anzeige
vom shop
wir brauchen
ob es msi ist oder sowas ist erstmal
ja warum
ne das können wir schon anzeigen
mein aktuell
lese ich da alle sachen aus aber
was es genau für eine grafikkarte ist
ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt
lass das querql lachen wenn ein artikel deutlich
über der uwp ist das ist das ist tatsächlich
eine gute idee so brand
created brauchen wir all die brauchen wir nicht
den preis brauchen wir die serie
brauchen wir nicht die haben wir schon
den shop nicht
also das ist
die haben wir schon den shop
name brauchen wir und die url zum
produkt
so genau
exellent
deswegen mag ich craftql
mittlerweile ist total easy so ein scheiß abzufragen
vor allem kannst du hier oben sogar noch
wenn man ganz hart drauf ist kann man hier oben sogar noch filtern
und sowas so serious
das ganze nur für
30 90
zack das kriegen wir nur 30
90 der crawlt regelmäßig
die ganze zeit was meinst warum ich so eine hohe cpu
last hab grad lokal ich sollte
mal wieder ausmachen
so dann machen wir mal
ein query rein und gucken ob es funst
query muss ich mal kurz
abgucken
oh was hab ich denn
da gemacht
stack overflow
stack overflow driven sind wir mal wieder
wir gucken wie es geht
queries
oh data
hat mich früher total zur verzweiflung gebracht
so sehr dass ich nie wieder was mitgemacht hab
craftql ist dagegen
richtig richtig
moment richtig
aber richtig
ok so ging das
mit dem query abfragen
wir machen jetzt hier gleich noch loading spinner
also
dann müssen wir das hier mal reinschreiben
dass wir das abfragen wollen
ging das nochmal hier
ja jetzt
ja ja jetzt merke da dass das nicht funktioniert ich weiß
weiß doch das
achso jetzt muss ich das
noch importieren
der frontend boss ist wieder am start
ihr habt es schon richtig erkannt eben
so
abfragen
hallo geht natürlich nicht aber
unser query
von eben können wir nehmen
wow
missing world at
haha
also
sehr schön so dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal
unser abgefragtes zeug anzeigen
irgendwo keine ahnung
hier drin ist erstmal wurscht
history lasts
ja
das ist das ganze zeug was der abfragt
ok der fragt jetzt zwar
hardcoded ab
für eine 3090 das ist jetzt aber
zum aufbauen von dem menü erstmal
wurscht
der fragt gerade hardcoded das können wir aber später
ändern dass wir das nicht mal hardcoded
abfragen
der nvidia sniper
ich hab schon überlegt
wenn es verschiedene crawler gibt
die unterschiedlich gut sind
könnte ich auch mehrere laufen lassen
und das alles ins fronten packen
aber das cheat margin
ist wirklich nice
so
gut jetzt müssen wir eine schleife machen
über die ganzen
abgefragten
dinger
also
wir machen das so
wenn das noch lädt
irgendwie konnte man sich das doch an
loading state
genau
if apollo loading
wenn das loadingt dann zeigen wir mal
loading an
loadet das überhaupt
ich muss kein loading anzeigen
so schnell geht das ja gut das ist ja auch lokal
und es ist ja auch nicht viel ehrlich gesagt
an daten das können wir eigentlich weglassen
so also
das heißt wir machen jetzt eine schleife
über
vor
äh keine ahnung
ähm was ist denn das
snapshot in
äh
ist sorry last
oder so
oh was habe ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht
key
key gleich
äh key
oh
achso ja was hat er jetzt
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen
im shop
shop
ok
ok jetzt haben wir eine schleife
über alle shops die die 3090
haben
kannst du für die noobs erklären was da alles abgeht
mit den verschiedenen programm ich mach ne website
im endeffekt mittlerweile ist es ja so
dass wenn man javascript zeug programmieren will
dass man erstmal das halbe internet installieren muss
weil javascript leute das gerne haben
javascript leute haben ja auch
npm packages für
is even is odd das jetzt keinen
wisst also das ist jetzt
das ist das habe ich nicht vorher
gepusht oder so also
es gibt allen ernstens ein javascript package
is even is odd
es ist ja nicht so als gäbe es
keine andere
möglichkeiten festzustellen
ob ne zahl jetzt äh
gerade oder ungerade ist
man könnte zum beispiel ne zahl
durch 2 teilen und den rest gucken
oder irgendwie sowas also
wir gucken uns mal den sourcecode an
is odd github npm
wir gucken uns jetzt mal
den sourcecode von diesem tollen
das weiß ich nicht
wieder einfach in der
Woche 450.000
mal runtergeladen wird
package states von was ist es abhängig
warum ist das überhaupt von irgendwas abhängig
ne ist das gar nicht
nur def also
huge sourcecode
ja dafür braucht man ein eigenes package
ganz wichtig
im prinzip macht er
genau das was ich gesagt hab
äh
ja
genau
ja odd
gleich eins
warte mal
warte mal warte mal moment
ach das ist modulu ah jetzt hab ichs
jetzt hab ichs ich hab mich verguckt
also super dafür braucht man natürlich
ein package
also
so ist das javascript mäßig
die brauchen
30.000.000 pakete ohne ohne geht nicht
nicht möglich
äh das ist übrigens falsch verständlich gemacht ich will das list item
generieren
will das list das list item will ich
generieren list item
list item
jetzt
jetzt kann man das
rein
ist das überhaupt
richtig grad
ähm
da haben wirs ihh da ist ja wieder ein scroll
balken
was denken die sich
mit ihren 30.000.000 scroll balken da immer
vor diesen scroll balken
machen sollen sie lieber das popup
komplett
äh
scroll balken ist scroll scroll balken ist
woodface
so das stimmt jetzt natürlich nicht was da steht
es ist nicht asus
sondern es ist
ähh
wie hab ich den kram genannt
shop
snapshot ist mir zu lang
das heißt jetzt einfach ihh
inf nee ihh
ihh beste
dass man immer
immer genau weiß was es ist
shop ok minefactual
alternate computer universe
ähh
capitalize
der erste da ist ja auch nicht eingebaut
javascript braucht man auch eine eigene funktion
das ist der erste buchstab groß jawoll
dankeschön für die subs
massive oh 5
stück der virus
bln 5 5 subs gegiftet
exellent
massive iq increase dankeschön für die subs
wir haben was gekriegt kgaming.de
tomba 2 6
1 2
brombeerpilot xniels
und mypsilmy
exellent
und der virus hat selbst noch mal abonniert
dankeschön für die subs
hätt ich jetzt mal mehr emotes
dann würd's wenigstens auch was bringen
wenn man wenn man zappt
weil aktuell es gibt die emotes sind äußerst poggers
die wir haben aber hätt ich mal von
hätt ich mich da mal früher drum gekümmert
mit ein paar tricks zusammen dann hätt ich jetzt von 28
emotes slots nicht nur 8
so also
minefact wie alternate computer
übers overclockers
asus case king amazon
oder wie die coolen Leute sagen
amazon
so
ja das ist doch als popup eigentlich schon mal
ganz cool was schreibt man da jetzt
noch rein
moment moment warte mal warte mal was ich da
gemacht hab ist das stimmt nicht das stimmt
nicht was ich da gebaut hab
wir brauchen jetzt erst noch mal komm ich brauch
mal einen gescheiten namen dafür das ist
ähm
das ist weiterhin i
i äh ne nicht i
stopp nein nein nein
i ähm das dato
muss da noch rein preis
preis
minus eins ist es bei
asus asus
asus ist es minus
eins warum denn
das
jetzt probieren wir gleich mal aus warum es bei
asus minus eins ist
so äh äh shop
moment link
link ist nicht keq
link ist
haben wir ja die url link
ist i.url
so und jetzt haben wir
eine link zu asus
ok die asus abfragen debatet einfach
nur asus preis minus eins
wie hab ich das nochmal
gemacht mit dem
mit dem preis
pix2
ok
euro
oh
achso
das euro symbol muss dahinter
so der sieht doch jetzt schon mal ganz
brauchbar aus
das heißt
wenn man das hier anklickt
dann kommt man zu den shops
exellent
so wir sollten das noch sortieren
das billigste zuerst und wir müssen
preise raus filtern
die äh minus
haben
preise die minus sind wollen wir nicht
das filtern wir am besten schon im
backend wobei
ne das filtern wir nicht im backend raus
weil ich will ja trotzdem anzeigen dass die was haben
wir zeigen aber keine preise an
die minus eins sind
wir sagen wenn das minus eins ist
dann zeigen wir irgendwie
not available oder irgendwie sowas an
kein preis schreiben wir dann dahin
also wenn der preis minus eins
irgendwie so machen
wenn preis
kleiner null
dann
kein preis
kein preis verfügbar
dass auch die noobs wissen was sache ist
für sortieren kannst du die order bypipe echt
was gibts
moment
warum ist da noch overclockers drin
ich hab overclockers rausgenommen
achso fund
und das ist ein fucking
ryzen
okay mein filter ist kaputt
what
ah
ich filter ja auch gar nicht
null w und und
serious
ja
ich hab gar nicht gefiltert
wieso nicht den preis erst anzeigen wenn er
über der ovp weil es kacke aussieht wenn da kein preis steht
du kannst davon ausgehen dass der preis immer
über der ovp ist
nochmal laden
kein preis verfügbar
okay jetzt haben wir auch das richtige
also moment
man kann da echt
view loop order by
das hab ich noch nie gemacht ich weiß gar nicht dass das geht
ey das ist ja cool
also ich muss echt sagen
die view leute sind wirklich
exquisite big brain
da kannst du nix sagen
eh order by
hat jetzt verschmerzen
eh wie geht das jetzt habe ich das falsch gemacht
was
gibt es nicht mehr
ist weg
you got
debated
soll ich irgendeine
custom library verwenden
okay
soll ich irgendeine custom library verwenden
ne
gut ich meine es ist ja nicht so als wäre das
ich installiere doch nicht
irgendwelche komischen extra libraries dafür
ne
ist das nicht sogar sortiert
aber ich kann das einfach
im backend sortieren
sort
ups
ne
sort
ne order
ist es ne order by haben wir schon
und genau
order by
descending
ups
alter der input lag
ja heute mal richtig krass
price
da wird doch schon sortiert
ja da wird
da wird sortiert nach created ad
warum auch
immer
ah ne ne ne das ergibt
das ergibt schon sinn
ich gucke erstmal ob die sachen innerhalb der letzten
viertel stunde sind weil danach sind sie nicht mal verfügbar
wenn sie gut gefragt sind
dann gucke ich ob die serie stimmt
dann sortiere ich
dass das oberste
das oberste das letzte ist
dann nehme ich mir
pro shop nur das letzte raus
und das was übrig geblieben ist das order
ich nochmal nach dem price
im craftql
query sortieren das geht wahrscheinlich auch ja
craftql sort
das ist ne gute
das probieren wir gleich mal aus das habe ich nämlich schon drin
aber jetzt müsste es auch schon stimmen
ja guckt jetzt ist richtig
aber ich mach das mal im craftql
das interessiert mich wie das funktioniert
so wir machen das aus dem
backend wieder raus dass es wieder schepp ist
oh und wir gehen mal ins
craftql und gucken wie man das
sortet ja
reloade dich
haben wir es jetzt
ja
jetzt
hallo warum darf ich nicht da drauf klicken
einfach reloaden dann darf ich vielleicht wieder
ausdrücken
exellent
so wie
sortiert man das jetzt irgendwie sort
ne
order
die craftql synthax waren schon ein bisschen komisch
order by price
und jetzt muss ich euch
noch eingeben auf desk oder ask
desk
boah ist das nice
ist das nice
das nehmen wir perfekt
bestes query
oder query
query wie mein
datenbanklehrer immer gesagt hat
datenbank query
der typ war egal der hat ja auch datenbank
datenbanken nicht datenbanken ausgefroren sei
immer gesagt datenbanken
in der datenbank
das datenbank query
ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen datenbank query
datenbank
eine
umfrage vorschlagen du kannst dir eine umfrage
vorschlagen ob was dir einfallen könnte
das nächste mal
und
richtig rom gesortet
das gute ist wenn wir das so sortieren
ist das hä ist das jetzt frontend
oder backend wo der das sortet
sortiert der das im craftql
backend oder sortet der das
nachdem er es bekommen hat
der
im beckern wird sortiert vermute ich jetzt
mal also wahrscheinlich
ist das was ich hier gemacht habe exakt das gleiche was
ich vorher hingeschrieben habe was er macht
ne das war babybeard ach ne
frischkäse
ne frischkäse ist der beste
im töpfchen wie hieß der denn
wie ist das denn dieses fass
fass
das meine ich das da
ne
das war so ein braunes fass
almette
almette kann sein almette kommt mir bekannt
von sowas hier sowas in der richtung
ja ja almette wahrscheinlich
ja ja
ja
in der richtung ja ja almette wahrscheinlich
was soll ich in der konsole gucken
ach du meinst was zurückkommt
ne in der konsole kann ich nicht gucken
aber ich kann
ich kann gucken was
netzwerkmäßig drüber geht
es ist schon sortiert
kommt schon sortiert an
exellent
so
also jetzt haben wir die liste sortiert das ist doch schon mal gut
was soll max im nächsten stream machen
c++ oder kobold
warum gibt es nur das als option und nichts
gescheites
schon wieder vorbei brauchen wir was anderes
mach andersrum
ja
einfach das ist einfach
so rum sortieren und zack ist es andersrum
aber dann fängt es mit kein preis an
kein preis sollte eigentlich
unten stehen oder
aber kein preis ist minus eins
siehste da wird schon wieder
komplizierter
was
ask plus eins
das funktioniert nicht oder
kein preis nicht anzeigen
ja nicht anzeigen ist doof
weil vielleicht gibt es das ja
aber das sollte unten sein da weiß ich jetzt grad
hab ich keine bessere idee das wie man das hinkriegt
ok wir brauchen aber noch ein paar andere
sachen also da soll ja nicht nur da soll ja nicht nur
drinne stehen
wann sondern es soll auch drinne
stehen
verfügbarkeit von wann es zuletzt
aktualisiert wurde
wenn wir richtig pro sind
dann schaffen wir sogar das es live
in dieser ansicht aktualisiert
dann muss ich aber hier
draus oh das wird das wird advanced
da muss ich hier draus kein query machen
sondern eine subscription
da kann ich das subscriben und kriegt dann
kriegt dann neue sachen
hast du mal was mit influxdb
gemacht ja für mein home assistant
die die statuswerte von
den ganzen sensoren und sowas
da ich dann im grafana
übersicht machen kann und chat
wisst ihr wisst ihr was ich noch für
einen graf im grafana hab bei mir daheim
gebt zu ihr wisst
wenn nicht muss ichs euch
zeigen
die heizung korrekt
die heizung genau
ich hab nen dashboard
für meine heizung wo man sieht was gerade angesagt ist
und heute ist er ganz schön am pumpen
ganz schön am pumpen die pumpe
brenner ist auch am brennen temperatur wird aber gut gehalten
passt alles kessel temperatur sieht auch gut aus
status ok abgas ok
exellent heizung gemonitort
alles gut
wir müssen da noch reinschreiben
also was meint ihr leute ist das
ist das eine gute idee wenn sich das hier aktualisiert
während man es auf hat
vielleicht ist es sogar besser wenn es sich nicht aktualisiert
das verwirrt
sonst die leute wenn das hier permanent
rumspringt
vielleicht ist es sortier nach
nach zeit auch besser
und nicht nach preis
ja das kann ich machen
aber das müsste ich machen bevor das hier
äh bevor ich das
in die schleife
fütter
kannst du das mal
anders ausführlich zeigen ja kann ich machen
ok also
jetzt zeigen wir erst nochmal
subtitel
zeigen wir jetzt nochmal
created ad
da sehen wir nämlich
ach nicht preis
da sehen wir nämlich wann es angelegt wurde
oja besser timestamp damit kann
natürlich jeder was anfangen
ok das ist jetzt nicht
noch besser
jetzt kann man es noch weniger lesen
was jetzt
oh ne es ist nicht to local time
es ist to local time string
to lokale
ok
das mit am und pm sieht bei euch dann anders aus
wenn ihr den browser auf englisch seht
da hab ich mit der musik grad los
9.37 also 21.35
ich mein vielleicht ist es auch sinnvoller
das nach zeit zu sortieren was meint ihr
nach zeit und nach preis ich will sagen
nach preis
und unten drunter kannst du dann anzeigen lassen
weil das ist einfach so das ding zeigt
eh nur an was die letzten
15 minuten also
verfügbar ist es eh nur wenn es die letzten
15 minuten da war
ansonsten ist der shop
gar nicht in der liste also 15 minuten
ist cut wenn es innerhalb von
15 minuten nicht erneut gecrawlt
wurde und ok ist fliegt
raus
aber so wirklich schick finde
ich das immer noch nicht aber das
brauchen auf jeden fall nochmal
jo
und wie weiter
dass es da ein schönes strich
unten drunter gibt
ach nee moment
list item
das funktioniert gar nicht
ich muss da doch ein diff drumrum machen
ich muss das doch in diff machen
diff
was ist das eigentlich für exquisite
musik die da
dudelt
so ok sieht schon besser aus
darfst du die emotes
einfach so verwenden
ich glaube da kräht kein
Hahn danach ob ich da einen
keck w mann mit
mütze anzeige oder nicht
kann man den avatar vielleicht
noch eckig machen
rounded
tile
dann ist es
eckig
oh viel besser leute
viel besser
der muss eckig sein oder
dass man ihn auch erkennt
musik
wisst ihr was ich gebe einfach in der
config jedem shop ein eigenes
emote
dann sind unterschiedliche
emotes da am start
das sieht doch lustiger aus
ich meine das ist auch die stonks anzeige
achja wir müssen
auch reinschreiben was man sich hier übrigens überhaupt
anguckt fällt mir gerade auf
also das hier ist nicht nur stonks
das ist überschrift
musik
wie war das
title war das so
ahja genau
musik
schön
schön ist was anderes jetzt
bin da nicht so der frontend champ
emotes auf den preis
das ist ne gute idee abweichend
emotes abweichend
vom uvp
ja das ist witzig
emotes abweichend vom uvp
am ende am ende kommt
an der hier
wenn du eine feste
ablaufende zeit sparen hast dann mach doch irgendwie
eine uhr hinter oh jetzt
jetzt massive alter
musik
Namen rein. Ja. Ich könnte noch Pretty Long machen, also nicht den hier, sondern schöner
Text mit, da könnte ich nämlich hier oben schreiben, da könnte ich nämlich hier oben
reinschreiben. Nvidia RTX, Nvidia GeForce RTX 3090. Das machen wir jetzt noch, das
probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Serious, oh da muss ich aber neu starten.
Long Gachibars. Wobei, weißt du was, da brauche ich jetzt einfach Description für ein Gutes.
Wie heißt das Ding offiziell? Nvidia RTX GeForce. Wie nennt man das Teil? Nvidia
GeForce RTX 3090. Jetzt schreiben sie alles groß auf einmal. Das TM mache ich da nicht
dahinter. Und by the way, wisst ihr, dass sich das live updated? Schreibt es jetzt hier dahinter,
dann sendet er das ans Frontend und schon kann ich es verwenden. Description. Ach Moment,
das ist ja auch keqw, das ist ja auch die RTX 3060. 3060 Ti. Schreibt man Ti so? Guck da,
BAM, hat es automatisch geupdatet. Da schickt das, da schickt das immer wieder. Moment,
wenn sich das automatisch updatet. Ah ne, die anderen Sachen updaten sich aber nicht
automatisch, ja. Okay, das ist schon mal nice. Gibt es einen GPU Icon? GPU? Extension Card.
Wenn ich will mal kurz gucken wie das aussieht, sieht wahrscheinlich kacke aus. B-Icon, wat?
B-Icon. M-D-E. Oh. Hm. Das sieht auch gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Preis-Champ darf? Preis-Champ kann auf MineFactory zugreifen. Guck. Größer? Ach Moment,
das ist ja der Close-Button, lull. So. Was ist das denn? Was ist das denn? Was ist das
denn? Was passiert eigentlich? Warte mal, ich probier mal was Leute. So? Oder in die Mitte,
was meint ihr? So oder in die Mitte? Oder mal hinten dran probieren? Oder mal Mitte?
Excellent. So lassen wir das. Sehr schön. Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob ich
das mit dem Asus-Preis machen soll. Nein. Der Asus-Preis soll unten hin, aber das ist
erstmal nicht unser Problem. Was jetzt noch cool wäre? Senpi, was würdest du denn vorschlagen?
Ich find's auch nicht so toll, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Es geht ja jetzt erstmal, aber das
was der Sirius Max gebaut hat ist eindeutig schöner. Das sieht so leer aus und so. Da
fehlt doch noch ein bisschen was. So, CraftQL ist doch der neue Scheiße. Also Preisverlauf
können wir hier oben hin machen. Verfügbarkeit, History juckt wahrscheinlich niemand, weil
was interessiert mich, ob das vor zwei Wochen mal verfügbar war, aber eine Price-History
wäre glaube ich ganz praktisch. Die Items ohne Preis vielleicht in einer zweiten Sektion
nach unten? Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Oder wir machen? Ach weißt du was? Du hast
recht. Nee, ich mach's in einer, aber Computed Property klingt sinnvoll. Dann machen wir
nämlich, ja. Läuft das auf Netscape? Wir haben es letztens auf dem Internet Explorer
funktioniert, geht nicht. Eine Verfügbarkeitscraft wäre schon geil, aber nur für jeden einzelnen
Shop. Naja. Das gibt bestimmt eine Craft Library, wo man neben anklicken kann, was
man haben will. Guck hier in Grafana geht das ja auch. Wenn man in Grafana mehrere Sachen
hat, weiß gar nicht, ob ich das hier hab. Nee hab ich nicht. Da kann man auch hier unten
hier anklicken, also wenn man mehrere Sachen hat, ob man das sehen will oder nicht. Das
gibt es bestimmt eine fertige JavaScript Craft Library. Mach die Zeit nach unten rechts.
Problem ist, die haben ganz schön viel Platz hier. Vielleicht soll ich es doch nicht so
groß werden lassen. Also doch. Maximum 400 oder so. Oh. Warte. Hab ich das jetzt an der
falschen Stelle gemacht? Da muss ich es machen. Ich mein. Wär auch eine Möglichkeit. Das
ist bei mir daheim, ja. Wer hat das Serious Max hier gemacht? Ja, das ist natürlich schon
mal viel, viel nicer. Ach, guck mal. Ja, das ist eigentlich auch cool, oder? Naja, gut.
Bild kann ich nicht anzeigen lassen, so ohne weiteres. Da müsste ich mir für jedes Produkt,
was ich da reinmache, ein Bild raussuchen. Ich mein, ich könnte ein Bild von einer 3090
rein machen. Aber übrigens, was wir ganz vergessen haben, bei mein Factory ist es ja
gar nicht eine 3090. Ich weiß ja sogar, welche 3090 das ist. Bild vom Shop ziehen? Ne, Bild
vom Shop ziehe ich nicht. Wenn ich ein Bild von dem Shop ausliefe, erringen sie sich
eventuell drüber auf. Ich könnte aber verlinken auf das Logo bei denen. Aber ich will lieber
Emotes haben davor. Okay, dann probieren wir das mal aus. 3090, also ich weiß ja auch
noch, was es für eine Karte ist. Und zwar, wo wir mal gucken, ob ich das hier drinstehen
hab. Brand ist das, glaube ich. Asus. Genau, das ist nämlich der Hersteller von der Karte.
Weiß der auch, weiß der noch mehr da drüber? Warte mal, jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
bei mir. Guck mal, der weiß sogar, was das für ein Modell ist. Twin Edge OC. Es ist
nicht preisjam.org, es ist beta.preisjam.org. Wenn ihr auf preisjam.org geht, dann gibt's
Kappa 1, 2, 3. Brand. Warte mal, hat der noch was? Das speichere ich mir, glaube ich, gar
nicht. Serious Pride. Nein, das speichere ich. Okay, das habe ich nicht in der Datenbank
drinstehen, da kann ich das nicht verwenden. Aber das Brand, das könnte man eigentlich
noch da hinten irgendwo anzeigen, ne? Ach, wobei. Müssen Sie es nicht übertreiben.
Ich meine, juckt das wirklich irgendjemand, welcher Hersteller die Grafikkarte ist? Wenn
die Leute sehen, in 17, da klicken sie einfach drauf. Sehen, ah, das ist eine wassergekühlte,
die will ich nicht. Und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, umso mehr Linkklicks, falls ich da mal Reflinks
mache. Okay, na, wenn ihr das wissen wollt. Mir fällt übrigens gerade ein, ein Shop kann
durchaus mehrere im Angebot haben. Das wird ein bisschen zu kompliziert, das atet schon
wieder aus, weil es könnte ja sein, dass, warum ist der Auffahrglocker überhaupt noch
dabei? Die habe ich doch rausgeschmissen. Aber mir Lokale habe ich die nicht rausgeschmissen.
Mach ich jetzt mal. Äh, der checkt? Kann der Notebooks, konnte der Notebooks billiger?
Ach so, ja Moment, das ist das, was ich lokal habe. Ähm, ich glaube, online habe ich mehr.
Sag mal, werde ich jetzt wieder gededost? Sobald ich die IP zeige, ist der Dedos raus,
oder was? Guckst du euch an? Das ist doch ein Witz, oder? Das ist immer abends, wenn
ich striebe. Komischer. Aber ich habe das schon hinter Cloudflare umgezogen. Ach, Moment,
ich bin da schon poggers. Russische Botnet ist wieder am Start. Also mein, nee, nehmen
wir schon. Also Minefactory, Alternate, Caseking, Computer Universe, Equipa, Media Markt, Saturn.
NVIDIA selbst haben wir nicht. Street. Wir gucken mal, ob das überhaupt NVIDIA selbst
kann. Trojaner schon installiert, easy. Erstmal ist das H-Key geknackt. Was für Shops kann
der Kram? Kann der NVIDIA selbst? US. NVIDIA, NVIDIA AP. Ah, man trägt da Country
Teacher. Wo ist denn der Unterschied zwischen NVIDIA AP und NVIDIA? NVIDIA AP geht über
irgendeine Schnittstelle und NVIDIA crawlt die Seite wahrscheinlich. Ja, was ist denn
da besser? Keine Ahnung. Machen wir noch dabei. Vorne ausmachen. Ist ja gut. Geh aus. Hier,
das ist schon komisch. Immer wenn ich mich da im Stream drauf connecte, ist jemand lustig.
Oder ist da trotzdem irgendwas damit zu tun, dass ich da eingeloggt bin? Ich hab's gesehen,
es hat irgendwie 150.000 Packages. Die Kilkommodates sind wieder weg. Jetzt sind sie wieder drauf.
13 Dankeschön für die 16 Monate. Massive Subscription. In der Notebooks Billiga hab
ich drauf, ja. Leute, das ist kein Zufall. Irgendjemand hat sein Russen Botnetz immer
am Start, wenn ich das im Stream zeige. Oder ist Hetzener selbst. NVIDIA. NVIDIA AP. Wollen
wir mal gucken. Funktioniert das auch was? Cloudflare. Nee, die Seite ist ja noch nicht
hinter Cloudflare. Beta-Preis-Champ ist nicht hinter der IP-Rate-Limit. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das... Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock, das zu analysieren. Ich mach einfach
Cloudflare dafür und gut ist. So, Country brauchen wir noch. Germany. Ist schon komisch,
dass das immer im Stream kommt. Sehr, sehr merkwürdig, oder? Ich mein, dass ich live
im Stream sauer kanns ja schlecht dran liegen. Ist das wirklich nur im Stream? Ja. Also wenn
ich auf den Graph gucke, ist das nur im Stream. Okay. Start. Aber der sollte sich jetzt wieder
starten. So, läuft wieder. Gucken wir mal ob da Preis-Champ. Was für eine Bandbreite.
Oh, eine. Soll ich euch nochmal die Hetzner-Crafts zeigen? Dann muss ich euch einmal kurz ausmachen
und mich einloggen. Ich hab ja mittlerweile auch zwei Factor-Authentifizierungen an und
sowas. Warte mal, ich log mich mal kurz ein. Dauert kurz, weil das Passwort ist recht lang.
Okay, um.
OTP. Jetzt muss ich noch meine Authentifizierungen
aufmachen. Zu Factor-Authentifizierung. Okay, so, ich bin eingeloggt. Cloud. Also ich
zeig's euch mal. So, also das sind die zwei Kisten. Ich mach da noch ne Cloudflare-Protected-Kiste,
weil die kann ich ja schlecht nehmen, wenn man die IPs sieht. So, ähm. Beziehungsweise
ich mach ne andere IP. Also, ähm. Crafts. Auffällig, auffällig. 30 Tags sind ein bisschen
viel. Mach mal 24 Stunden. Den 24 Stunden-Hetzner. Auf geht's. Ist schon sehr auffällig. Ist
schon sehr auffällig, oder? Wann das immer auftritt? Wann war ne Woche? Was? Okay. Hezner,
mach mal. Hezner mag nicht mehr. Kann auch einfach Wartung sein. Hm. Das glaub ich nicht,
das ist schon auffällig. Ey, ich mein, das ist schon sehr merkwürdig hier, oder? Was
ich aber merkwürdig finde, dass das überhaupt die Kiste zum Abkacken bringt. War das jetzt
ne Week? Hm. Oder vielleicht DDoS'd mich doch keiner? Guckt mal. Das ist auch nachts
irgendwann. Ne, ich mein, das sind 100.000 Packages per second, das ist unglaublich viel.
Und es ist Out-Traffic. Aber warum ist der Out-Traffic manchmal einfach so hoch? Der
Server DDoS'd sich selber? Das ist die neue, das ist die neue Vollinstalliert bei Hezner-Taktik.
Der Server DDoS'd andere, genau. Komisch. Mein Botnet, fuck, jetzt ist es raus. Es ist
aber schon... Aber guckt mal hier, das ist... Aber es geht auch mit Natural. In. Also eigentlich,
Leute, eigentlich hätte ich erwartet, dass der Traffic in höher ist. Weil Traffic in
höher ist ja die Antworten beispielsweise auf mein Crawling-Zeug. Guckt mal, 12 Stunden.
Alter, Hezner, komm an. Lad, lad, lad den Craft, ey. Guckt normalerweise ist in auch
immer höher. Aber ab und zu... Out-Traffic, was ist der Out-Traffic so hoch? Was macht
der denn ab und zu? Aus welchen Gründen auch immer sollte ich denn auf einmal 100.000 Packages
Out-Traffic haben? Das ist der richtige, ja, ja. Aber Out-Traffic, seh ich net. Guckt
mal, wir hatten vor einer Woche, ging's mal richtig ab. Vor einer Woche, da hatte Hezner
Probleme hier. Aber das sind auch nur 60.000. Die Anzeigen sind irgendwie sehr merkwürdig.
Hä? Der Craft sieht jetzt wieder komplett anders aus. Warte mal, 12 Stunden. Moment,
war ich eben auf dem falschen Server? Hä? Ich, ich war doch auf dem richtigen Server
eben. Hä? Bin ich, aber guck mal jetzt. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Warum sehe
ich bei einer Stunde die Packages auf 50.000 und auf 12 Stunden net? Ach so, weil das nur
bis 20. Nee, doch. Sag mal. Bin ich jetzt total beschissen? Wir haben das doch eben selbst gesehen zusammen im Stream. Ihr habt's doch auch gesehen, oder? Ich mach kein Backup, wer braucht Backup?
Backup overrated, she baited. Okay, Max. Guckt mal!
Hä? Was? Moment, das war jetzt, das war jetzt PP. Ach, war das einfach ein Network Traffic,
wenn ich geguckt hab? Hier. Seht ihr das? Das ist der Server und die Crafts bei Hetzner
ergeben überhaupt keinen Sinn. Warum zeigt das so unterschiedliches Zeug an? Kann es
sein, dass das doch, dass ich weder DDoS noch mein Server was hat, sondern das Hetzner
jedenfalls. Das war jetzt gerade live. Komm mal, jetzt ist es wieder. Ne. Moment, was? 19 Uhr?
Das sind jetzt 24 Stunden. Ja, so würde ich, so würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht.
So würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht. Dass ich hauptsächlich Input Traffic hab.
Checkt es net. Ah ja, okay. Die Crafts sehen jedes Mal anders aus, wenn ich mir die angucke,
oder? Sieht jedes Mal anders aus, wenn ich mir die Crafts angucke. Okay, was auch immer.
Was auch immer. Lege ich net. Aber so würde ich erwarten, dass das aussieht. Und by the
way, was auch sehr komisch ist, wenn ich auf eine Woche gehe, dann taucht das hier gar nicht
auf, wenn ich auf 10, 20 Stunden gehe. 10, 20 Stunden auch nicht. Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Das verwirrt mich echt hardcore. Doch Beta-Preis-Champ hat IPv6-Einträge. Doch, doch, haben wir gemacht.
Äh, by the way, wie ausgelastet ist das Ding? Geht eigentlich. Also jetzt haben wir Nvidia
auf jeden Fall auch noch dabei. Gut, ich mach mal wieder zu. SDBA42, Dankeschön für
den Sub. Massive Subscription. So, eine Sache machen wir jetzt noch. Ich wollte es zumindest
mal fertig machen. Wo sind wir jetzt gerade stehen? Wo sind wir denn davor stehen geblieben,
Leute? Das nehme ich schon spät. Ich gehe gleich pennen. Äh, das haben wir gemacht.
Das sieht eigentlich ganz nett aus. Man hat hier die Anzeige. Was ist denn bisher der Change
für heute? Eigentlich haben wir nur das Pop-Up gemacht. So, genau, stimmt, stimmt. Ich wollte
noch einplenden, das Brand. Wo plenden wir denn den Grafikkartenhersteller ein? Die Sache
ist die, eigentlich müsste man da noch mehr machen, weil es könnte ja sein. Was, hat
keine IPv6-Einträge? Dann habe ich es bei Cloudflare vielleicht verkackt. Ihrpreisjam.org
hat IPv6, weil es Cloudflare ist. Das passt. So, was ich aber nicht verstehe ist, ne, also
was ein bisschen kompliziert ist, es könnte ja sein, dass ein Shop mehrere 30.90 im Angebot
hat von unterschiedlichen Herstellern. Das fast wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht aufmachen,
wenn ich ehrlich bin. Deswegen, der soll immer die billigste anzeigen. Der soll immer
die billigste anzeigen. Das muss ich übrigens hier im Backend auch noch machen, sonst funktioniert
das gar nicht. Weil ich sag hier Order by Minutes und dann muss ich noch sagen, ne, wobei
ich zeige die letzte an, die letzte ist besser, die letzte ist besser. Ne, passt, das ist
egal. Die Seite ist tot, ja, kann sein. Das russische Botnetz ist am Start. Was kostet
sich die Webseite voraussichtlich? Das ist der fetteste Server, der ist relativ teuer.
Muss ich mal gucken. Wahrscheinlich 60 Euro oder so, aber ich werde das noch umziehen.
Passte alles. Leute, wisst ihr was, wir machen morgen weiter. Ich gehe jetzt pennen und dann
bauen wir das morgen noch ein bisschen aus. Also Leute, alles klar, wir sehen uns. Bis
dann, machts gut, see you. Wann morgen, weiß ich schon nicht.